[Music]  someone once told me  that the reality i thought i knew  was just one  of many  be careful which paths you travel down  stronger than you have lost their way  [Music]  you think there will be no consequences  we're in the end game now  i sacrificed everything  and it meant  nothing  oh strange  what have you done  i never meant for this to happen  you cannot control everything  you brought this  on yourself  [Music]  you break the rules and become a hero  i do it and i become the enemy  this doesn't seem faint  doctor screen to the multiverse of  madness video pg-13 be the first to see  the mind-bending phenomenon in premium  large format in imax tomorrow  [Music]  you